all right so you want to lose weight
hopefully you started the ketogenic diet
and you want to take your results to the
next level well you're already drinking
water might as well add a few things to
take it to the next level the first
thing to realize is that weight is a
symptom it's not the problem it's not
the cause the underlying cause is too
much insulin a couple things about
insulin that you may already know this
is just a refresher insulin is the main
fat storing hormone in the presence of
eating a little bit of insulin you can't
burn fat so insulin prevents the burning
of fat and when you have too much
insulin over time you develop something
called insulin resistance now at first
you might think this is a good thing
because insulin resistance sounds like
you're resisting insulin so you'll
actually lose weight but in reality what
happens with insulin resistance is the
body overcompensates and has to make a
lot more insulin to penetrate this
resistance so people that have insulin
resistance have a lot more insulin okay
and that's the problem and of course you
get insulin resistance by having too
much insulin because your body is trying
to protect you against too much of it so
it develops this barrier but this whole
thing gets worse over time unless the
triggers to insulin are addressed you
may already know this but there's three
things that trigger insulin carbs
trigger insulin especially the more
refined the carb is like sugar
also eating triggers insulin this is why
frequent eating and snacks are really
bad but the third thing which I just
talked about is having insulin
resistance okay that is the thing that
will just increase more insulin and
there's just one more really important
thing that I want to explain to you
when you have insulin resistance which
the majority of the population has and
they get on a low carb diet they cut out
carbs eating no sugar and then they
check their blood sugars and the sugar
goes higher or for example they're a
diabetic and the sugar just keeps going
higher but they're not eating any sugar
that sugar is coming from somewhere it's
coming from the liver the liver is
converting other things like fat like
protein like ketones into sugar this is
called gluconeogenesis
and so the worst insulin resistance that
you had going into this the more you
might find your blood sugars are still a
bit high for a while all you have to do
is continue this program push through it
do what I'm going to tell you next and
over time that blood sugar will come
down but that extra sugar in your blood
is not coming from your diet it's coming
from your liver making this other
conversion should probably just mention
one thing too if someone is overweight
or they're a diabetic or they have
insulin resistance there's going to be
this it's called a basal insulin level
like an underlying level of insulin that
your body is operating off of just to
keep things in check that has nothing to
do with what you're eating or whatever
but there's just going to be higher
amounts of insulin flowing through your
blood if you are overweight or you're
diabetic or you have insulin resistance
so I just want to bring that up because
some people expect the same weight loss
as their spouse but maybe their spouse
doesn't have insulin resistance is bad
so because your basal or basic insulin
levels are just higher than they should
be because of years of insulin
resistance it's going to be a little bit
tougher to lose weight initially
compared to someone else who just
doesn't have that level of insulin
flowing through their bloodstream the
whole goal of this video is to hyper
focus on fixing this insulin resistance
problem so you can lose the most weight
possible in the shortest amount of time
so we want to compound things we want to
get you on a healthy version of the
ketogenic diet we want you to do
intermittent fasting but with your
fluids you can add just a few things
just to take it to the next level so
we're talking about three things lemon
apple cider vinegar
and cinnamon now if you were to add just
two maybe three of these drinks per day
you would see significant improvements
in your program and I'm talking about
weight loss because you're addressing
this insulin issue and even if you're
not perfect on the diet this will
actually improve things greatly all
right so let's first talk about apple
cider vinegar apple cider vinegar has
something called acetic acid acetic acid
is a potent blood sugar lowering
compound okay it will help make insulin
more sensitive and less resistant it
will help lower your blood sugars even
if you eat some carbs believe it or not
and there's some interesting studies
which I'll put down below okay and then
we get this lemon right you can do
either lemon juice or a whole lemon you
can either blend the whole lemon in the
blender it takes a little bit more when
you're cleaning things out but eating
the whole lemon gives you some
additional benefits if you have time but
if you don't have time just get some
lemon lemon juice and use that so in
lemon juice you have various things you
have citric acid you have phytonutrients
you'll have vitamin C if you juice to
the fresh lemon or blend the whole lemon
lemon juice that's contained in a glass
jar is usually pasteurized it's not raw
and because vitamin C is sensitive to
oxygen and heat it's pretty much going
to destroy that vitamin C but there are
other benefits of vitamin C especially
as you're trying to lose weight but the
phytonutrients in lemon juice make
insulin more sensitive and they make
insulin less resistant now the third
component and this is an extra thing
okay
cinnamon and you just put a pinch of the
cinnamon into this mixture cinnamon is
one of those things that has a potent
effect on making insulin more sensitive
and helping your blood sugars be more
regulated and one study they took a 543
diabetics and they tested this cinnamon
and the average person dropped their
blood sugars by 24 points which is very
significant so if you can just add a few
things to the liquid that you're already
drinking it's a no-brainer and we're
using a Compound Effect we're adding
several things actually we're adding
intermittent fasting keto lemon juice
we're adding cinnamon and apple cider
vinegar all of these things are going to
contribute and speed things up so you
can really get to your goal a lot faster
now the other cool thing about these
three things is that they all tend to
help reduce fat on your liver like I
said they reduce insulin they have blood
sugars they also help regulate your
cholesterol they help your liver make
more bile which has some benefits in
itself lemon water also has citrates to
decrease your risk of getting kidney
stones and all three are very
anti-inflammatory and too much
inflammation in the body can actually
create a situation where you have
insulin resistance so inflammation can
also trigger insulin resistance all
right so here are the instructions very
very simple
you can do this two or three times a day
you want to use 16 ounces of water
you're going to add either an ounce of
lemon juice or a whole lemon you can
either blend the whole lemon or just
squeeze the lemon juice from one lemon
into the water then add one to two
tablespoons of apple cider vinegar I
don't recommend Bragg's Apple Cider
Vinegar I recommend fairchilds because
that is the source behind Braggs and
they don't dilute it and I'm not
affiliated I don't get any Kickbacks but
that's a really Superior apple cider
vinegar it comes with the mother it's
organic and it's concentrated if you
look at the ingredients in Bragg's Apple
Cider Vinegar they add water so
basically they dilute it then take your
cinnamon and just put a pinch into this
container you can either shake it up or
blend it and so some people that drink
this might not like the taste okay it
might be too bitter so you might want to
add a few drops liquid Stevia if you
don't know what that is it's an extract
from a plant that's sweet without the
sugar and you just need a few drops and
it'll just taste just like lemonade or
some people use my electrolyte powder
one scoop and that way you get some
electrolytes with the sweetener which is
Stevia so after you mix this up I would
recommend drinking this before your
meals now if you're just doing one meal
a day first and second one are going to
be an empty stomach and the third one
will be right before a meal now the next
most important thing to understand is
how to do a ketogenic diet okay step by
step and I put that video up right here
check it out